this is a production of cornell
university
sir larry
all right so my name is zach stancil i
am the usda agricultural research
service uh hemp germplasm core curator
at the plant genetics resources unit in
geneva
so
amongst some other things i'm doing as
well anyways so in geneva the usda has a
really big presence here and we maintain
crop genetic resources collections so
for example we have the largest apple
collection in the world
y'all kind of probably saw it on
mccarthy
we also keep a collection of about 6 000
tomatoes which is amongst the largest in
the world
and and honestly many other crops so in
2020 we really got started on this
project of adding hemp
to our germplasm collections
so
why would we do this well there's a lot
of reasons
maintaining crop genetic diversity i
believe is an intrinsic good
maintaining
diverse cultivars from unique geographic
regions
long term can solve a lot of problems in
the future that we may we may not even
be aware of now
for example with cabbage we maintain a
cabbage accession that was collected in
the 1890s and still is available and
many times these older cultivars are
sources of our genes or resistance to
different
pathogens pests etc or contain
novel phenotypes so what you're seeing
right now is our first grow out of about
half of our collection
so since we i was here last year we had
zero accessions now we've got about 200.
um our plan is to grow that to 2 000 in
the next 10 years
so we're really just getting started
we are trying to
not just conserve this genetic diversity
but make it available to the entire hemp
breeding and research community
so
essentially
germplasm requesters can request a
sample of the seeds from every one of
these accessions and have them sent
anywhere in the world right
we are also extensively phenotyping this
collection for kind of a mind-boggling
number of traits so plant architectural
traits height width
growth architecture
every female plant is going to have
tissue sampled and sent off for
cannabinoid analysis terpene
anthocyanins phenolics
we're taking a sub-sample of seed for
fatty acid analysis
we'll be chop
we're trying to chop every single plant
out of this field at the end of the
season
and send to our fiber collaborator
crystal home
at the new orleans
fiber
usda fiber lab and he's going to be
evaluating these every plant for many
different
fiber characteristics so we'll get all
these huge data sets and attach them to
each accession
so a plant breeder could say like i want
a
cbg
dominant cultivar with low apical
dominance that has
low pectin i whatever you can think of
like you can you can find germplasm that
fits the set of criteria that you're
looking for so that's just a little bit
of what we're doing i'm going to pass it
off to our hemp breeder tyler gordon
as well by the way if you want to look
in the field you can scan the qr code on
the left
and that will link you to grin global
which is a online page for each one of
these accessions
it's kind of dip operate of data right
now but
by end of season we should have a lot
more
info there
is that okay
all right
thank you all for attending this
afternoon it looks like a terrific crowd
out there and we've heard some
fantastic
research studies that have been ongoing
this morning and
so really excited like zach to share a
little bit more about the usda
ars collection
my name is is tyler gordon and again i'm
with usda ars i came
just recently a few months ago from the
usda ars lab in idaho and there i worked
on small grains so the grain part of
hemp i'm very familiar with the
secondary metabolite profiles and fiber
not not too familiar with yet however as
zach mentioned we're going to be doing
lots of evaluations this year
i think we're going to take over 100
individual trait
data points from each one of these
plants here and that's going to be super
informative for breeders
regardless of what the in quality end
product is that you're breeding for
so whether that's fiber or or grain
secondary metabolites or or maybe a
combination of some of those things i
think that'll be really useful data
that'll be posted on the usda
grin global website so anyone
throughout the world has access to that
information
additionally i think zach mentioned this
the seeds from this collection are going
to be available to
re the research community
the one stipulation that we have from
these seeds is that they
in order for us to distribute them
they're going to have to be low thc so
if you're looking for those high thc
cultivars or varieties or accessions
you're not going to be able to get them
from us
one
thing that i would ask of you guys so
we're just kind of starting this this
pre-breeding program here
i'm hoping that you have access to the
qr codes i want to hand around our flyer
here
and if you would scan the qr code
there's a survey there and i'd like
everybody to kind of if if you're
interested in hemp material for your
breeding programs if you could scan the
qr code fill out the survey it's very
quick i think there's what 10 questions
or something and that can kind of help
us
determine what kind of breeding
priorities
we should set
for this material so we'll have all this
terrific data from this from this
location we also have a couple other
locations that we're going to be
collaborating with on the west coast so
oregon state washington state also
hoping to get developed collaborations
with some groups in the midwest and also
in the south to see how these plants
perform
across geographical locations i think
some of the other folks today have have
talked about the importance of
some genotypes might look terrific here
in geneva but they wouldn't necessarily
look
fabulous say in louisiana or alabama
and then one other thing i want to talk
about just a little bit is
some of the disease and insect
resistance that we heard about this
morning
that's i think one of the
really amazing things about these
collections
is
how they can harp they can act as a
reservoir for important um genetic
diversity and also important genes that
we might not even know we need
for the crop at this point
and so for instance
if there's a new disease that we're not
familiar with and it comes in 10 years
that's what these germplasm collections
are are here for is
you might have like a really ratty
looking
you can see some of this material out
here where
it's a land race or a ditch weed from
nebraska and it looks like it has no
value whatsoever but you screen that
against some new insect or disease and
you can find some really interesting
resistance there
and so again all this data is going to
be made
publicly available the germplasm is also
going to be available to the hemp
community
please fill out this the survey the
online survey that's really going to
help us
oh yeah yeah
and just
one other point i wanted to thank the
our field crew field team um zach and i
did not do all this work ourselves and
so i see some folks out here nick
dan
tony i saw peter earlier and so thank
you so much and i also wanted to thank
the organizers cornell for letting us
highlight this um terrific diversity in
in hip um and so if you have any
questions please let me know also please
feel free to walk through the material
as zach said where is that oh you have
the sign again at the start of each plot
is one of these signs
there's a qr code that will link you up
with grin
which is our online the usda online
genetic
database on the front side it gives you
some more information like the field
number the backside has the cultivar if
that's maybe more familiar with people
and so i can take questions at this
point or you can ask them at any point
the signs are on the north end of the
plot they're serpentine serpentine
so you're
you're gonna have to kind of look for on
it yeah
so let's say uh
right you're sending all these samples
to be uh tested out
we're measuring 100 different variables
of the phenotype but the expression of
the phenotype depends on a lot of
factors right so how
do you average over many seasons are
there's many sites or how does that work
that that's a really great question so
green global which is like tyler
mentioned our online database is
um really tooling up to capture these
robust high dimensional data sets so
kind of the old model was you had one
trade for that the tomatoes are yellow
the new grand model is such that we can
attach
large data sets that can capture
multi-year multi-environment trials
and keep those attached to not only the
accession but the the inventory the seed
lot within that accession
and then also
um
as these collections are genotyped those
markers will also be attached to the
accession as well
great question
come on there's got to be a few more
questions in here
yes go for it well then for the
similar for the genotype let's say
you're preserving uh
well you're preserving varieties
cultivars here
but if the if if the
cultivar originates from a different
environment does that is there a worry
or how do you deal with potentially the
genotype drifting or adapting to the
local environment yeah so that's the
the classic question in crop genetic
resource conservation right so
there are many different factors um
to maintain that allelic diversity the
heterozygosity within a population
um first of all we don't even really
know how heterozygous a lot of these
materials are i would guess
a lot there's a lot um but that probably
varies from cultivar to culture so
um in a perfect world you would maintain
an infinite population size
and store
a zillion seeds from that random mating
you can't do that with our seed bank
size and capacity and it's a few of us
so how do you find the sweet spot of
optimal population size
pollination control
running regens from older seed lots
there's a lot of best practices that you
can take
to maintain that genetic diversity long
term
you didn't ask this question but
our seed lots are also split up and
stored in multiple locations in the
event of something catastrophic
happening so we have a mothership
gene bank at uh fort collins colorado
that we'll send aliquots of the seeds to
and then those seeds in turn will get
backed up at this far bald seed vault in
norway and uh and according to a black
box
so
um that's something that's very much on
our mind and as hemp has not been
uh
conserved
in a rigorous scientific way
for the most part there's a lot we're
trying to learn so i'm pointing out some
of the work of nick jenna my postdoc
here so he's looking at how do you store
pollen long term
um it's there's just a lot of open
standing questions that we're trying to
drill into
that will you know provide a cohesive
set of principles
to maintain that genetic diversity long
term
and i just want to add really quickly
you've probably heard from some of the
other groups today about the
heterogeneity levels within things that
are even classified as cultivars and so
pay close attention as you move through
the field today
look you can see a label
and then there will be 10 plants behind
that level label and you'll see they
don't
all look alike or even close to like in
some cases sometimes within one cultivar
you'll have some plants that are five
feet tall and some that are less than a
foot tall and so that's something we
that's one of the priorities for the
breeding program is is to release stuff
that has a lot
more uniformity within the cultivar
great thanks very much tyler and zach
we are
very very fortunate to have uh the
hampton plaza repository here at cornell
agritech mpgru we thank senator schumer
for that
his office uh made the initial push
for that uh
location and we really appreciate that
because it's great to work with these
folks and we have immediate access to
their knowledge and resources
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu